Transcriber: Marina Naguib
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
من مخاطر الإنترنت وسلبيات التكنولوجيا،
كما تعلمون،
لعقود طويلة كانت البيئة التربوية هي
الأسرة والأهل
والمسجد والمدرسة.
وفي عصرنا الحالي أصبحت
هذه البيئة هي العالم كله.
فمنذ أن بدأت عملي في مجال
تكنولوجيا المعلومات والإنترنت،
قبل حوالي عشرين عامًا،
وأتلقى التساؤلات
والاستفسارات من الأهالي والآباء
والمعلمين والمعلمات
حول أثر التكنولوجيا على الأبناء،
والألعاب الإلكترونية أيضًا.
علمًا أنه كما تعلمون في ذلك الوقت كانت
سهلة وبسيطة، ولم تكن بهذا الإنتشار،
كما في الوقت الحالي.
وفي السنوات العشر الأخيرة،
الحقيقة ازدادت التحديات،
وازدادت الصعوبات والمشاكل
مع انتشار الإنترنت،
وازدياد الأجهزة الذكية
والألعاب الإلكترونية.
الحضور الكريم، لو طرحت عليكم سؤال أن منزل
أحدكم يسرق، ونحن جالسون في هذه القاعة.
ماذا سيكون رد فعلكم لهذا السؤال؟
إجابة هذا السؤال أخي الكريم
أو أختي الكريمة
أن بيتك يسرق في هذه اللحظة،
ونحن هنا في هذه القاعة.
طبعًا من الطبيعي أن أحدكم قد يقول:
أنا سأتصل بالأمن.
والآخر قد يقول: أنا قد أتصل بالجيران.
والآخر يقول: أنا سأتصل بأحد الأقارب؛
ليرى ماذا يحدث.
حسنًا، ماذا سيحدث؟
ماذا سيسرق هؤلاء من بيوتنا؟
أي إذا كان عندك 100 ألف ريال في البيت،
بإمكانك أن تعوضهم.
(ضحك وتصفيق)
وإذا كان عندك نصف كيلو ذهب
في البيت أو كيلو،
بإمكانك تعويضهم أيضًا.
وإذا سُرق البيت كاملًا بإمكانك تعويضه،
هذه أشياء مادية يمكن أن تُشترى مرة أخرى.
الحضور الكريم،
عقول أبنائنا تُسرق على مدار الوقت.
دون حسيب أو رقيب
أو حتى برامج حماية وضبط.
فلم يعد المربي هو من يربي فقط،
أصبح هناك شركاء آخرين.
فالقنوات الفضائية وما تبثه
من برامج ومشاهد،
وأيضًا المواقع الإلكترونية
وما تحمله بين طياتها،
وأيضًا أجهزة الألعاب الإلكترونية.
فأصبح هذا الجيل...
فأصبح أبناؤنا يعيشون في مُفترق الطرق.
في هذا الزمن، زمن الإنفتاح العشوائي.
وذلك سبب لهم الكثير الكثير من المشكلات،
وطبعًا المشكلات السلوكية والنفسية
وأيضًا الصحية.
الحضور الكريم، فكرتنا بأن
أبناءنا يتأذون دون أن نعلم.
ماذا سنفعل؟ لننقذهم قبل فوات الأوان.
ما رأيكم؟ جاهزين لننقذهم؟ جاهزين مستعدين؟
لذلك أطلقنا مبادرة
قبل حوالي
عشر سنوات.
بعنوان أبناؤنا
مشروعنا العظيم.
هل في أعظم من هذا المشروع في
أعظم من أبنائنا
مشروع أن يكون العظيم ذلك لأن
الأبناء الحضور الكريم انتبهوا .
الأبناء هم زهور الأمة ، والأبناء
هم أمل المستقبل .
وعلى مر العصور يشكل أبناء والأجيال
عنصر الإنتاج وعنصر التطوير وعنصر التغيير،
وعنصر أيضا التحديث .
فكيف لنا أن نصمت ؟ ونحن نرى
بأم أعيننا أبنائنا .
وقوتنا وطاقاتنا تتآكل .
وتستهلك .
وقدراتنا وخيراتنا .
تتناثر .
لقد أجمع المربون والتربية والتربويون
على أهمية التربية الواعية .
أهمية التربية الواعية لأنها ليشتري بالوعي
.
لماذا يجب أن يكون عندنا وعي في التربية؟
لأنها الضمان الأقوى
والأفضل للحفاظ على البيئة
التربوية السليمة، فلابد للمربين
من الوعي والإطلاع والقراءة لكل ما يحدث في
عصر الإنفتاح العشوائي ، ومن وسائل
التكنولوجيا ومواقع التواصل الإجتماعي
وأجهزة الألعاب الإلكترونية لذلك .
أيها الحضور الكريم لا بد من
تنمية قدرات الأبناء .
لا بد من تنمية قدرات الأبناء بكل أبعاد
هذه القدرات،
سواء كانت نفسية أو جسدية أو روحية
أو إجتماعية،
وتقوية الشخصية إلى أقصى حد
تسمح به إمكانياتهم وأيضًا
استعداداتهم .
السيدات والسادة .
الحضور الكريم .
خلال ساعة أو ساعات من الزمن هي مدة عرض
فيلم غير مناسب
أو متابعة قناة فضائية غير لائقة .
تمحو من عقول أبنائنا ما قام به المربين
والمعلمين والمدارس في تربيتهم وتعليمهم
وتثقيفهم لسنوات طويلة .
حان الوقت .
لندرب العقل والعاطفة .
وذلك بتنشيط الذكاء الروحي لدى الأبناء
والذي يساعد الأبناء .
على التخيل والإبداع والتفكر والتدبر أيضًا.
ويذكّر الأبناء بأنهم هدية من الله سبحانه
وتعالى،
وأنهم المعجزة في هذا الخلق في هذه الكائنات
الابن هو معجزة في الخلق أيضًا يذكرهم هذا
الذكاء الروحي
ويعلمهم ويدربهم على أنه
إنسانًا عظيمًا .
ويعطيه الثقة بنفسه وينمي قدراته
ويكون مستعدًا لمستقبله .
ولا بد من ممارسة الألعاب الإلكترونية التي
تحتاج إلى تنمية وتفكير لتحفيز المهارات
المهارات العقلية طبعًا، وأن ندرب
أجسامهم حتى تتدرب عقولهم .
لأن .
أيضًا نروي لهم قصص رموز الأمة
وأبطال هذه الأمة .
لأن .
التمارين الرياضية تكسب الإنسان
جسم سليم وعقل سليم .
بعد هذا الحضور الكريم .
ما هي الحلول لوقاية أبنائنا
من مخاطر التكنولوجيا والإنترنت؟
نريد حلول عملية .
نحن الحقيقة .
الحلول العملية أهمها نحن بحاجة إلى
مصلحين أكثر من حاجتنا لصالحين
صحيح، نحن بحاجة لماذا؟ لمصلحين
لماذا حاجتنا إلى المصلحين أكثر من حاجتنا
لصالحين؟
الحقيقة لأن الصالح .
الصالح يكتفي بحماية نفسه ، أما المصلح
يصلحوا الله به الأسرة .
والأهل والمجتمع والأمة .
نحن بحاجة .
لقوله تعالى بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم .
وما كان ربك ليلك القرى بظلم
وأهلها مصلحون.
أيضا الحضور الكريم .
يجب على كل واحد منا أن يقوم
بالواجب
بأن يكون لديه الإحساس بالواجب
الأخلاقي والمجتمعي لحماية الأبناء،
وأيضًا تنظيم أوقات الاستخدام للأجهزة
الإلكترونية،
أو لمواقع التواصل الإجتماعي
أو الهواتف الذكية.
وأن نكون أصدقاء لأبنائنا نحاورهم،
نلعب معهم، وننصح أيضًا بأنه
لا يجب على الأبناء دون عمر العشر سنوات أن
يكون لديهم أجهزة خاصة بهم ، وإن كانت
موجودة أن تكون الأجهزة موجودة في غرفة
المعيشة التي كل الناس تكون موجودة فيها
لكن ما رأيكم أن نغير هذا الاسم؟
غرفة المعيشة لاسم جديد إن
نسميها نحن من اليوم .
غرفة لليقظة .
ما رأيكم موفقين موافقين؟
لماذا نسميها بغرفة اليقظة؟ لنكون
مشرفين على أبنائنا
يقظين لما يشاهدونه وما يتابعونه
أيضًا ؟ أليس كذلك ؟
أيضًا الحضور الكريم انتبه .
انتبهوا انتبهوا .
لا بد لنا من استثمار ربيع
الوقت مع الأبناء .
عندما نكون في البيت آباء ، عندما أكون في
المدرسة معلمين نستثمر أوقاتنا مع أبنائنا
ومع طلبتنا لأن هذا يسمى ربيع الوقت .
نترك كل شيء أجهزة إلكترونية
ونترك الهواتف الذكية .
لماذا ؟ لأنه طبقنا نحن البداية
مبادرتنا يجهزها أبناءنا مشروعنا .
مشروعنا العظيم .
أيضا من الحلول حيث أبعد أيضا من الحلول .
يجب ألا نقوم بحظر أو فصل الإنترنت
نهائيًا،
ولكن نقوم بالإشراف عليهم ، وأن
لا تكون الأجهزة داخل غرفهم الخاصة.
ويجب تحذير الأبناء من استخدام
بياناتهم الشخصية .
كأرقام هواتفهم أو أسماء أحد ذويهم أو
صورهم الشخصية لما يترتب لذلك من عواقب
وقصص غير مرضية صحيح؟
أيضًا الحضور الكريم .
هذه الحلول التي قدمناها معكم حلول
قادرين ننفذها قادرين .
فما رأيكم أن نقدم لكم أيضًا حل أشمل وأقوى؟
ما رأيكم على تقديم حل أشمل وأقوى؟
إن شاء الله تعالى الحل من شقين من قسمين
القسم الأول هو العلاقات الأربعة.
علاقة أن ندرب أبناءنا وطلابنا
على علاقة الإنسان
بيمين بالخالق علاقة الإنسان بربه
، ومن ثم ودربه على علاقته مع ذاته
وتطويرها وتقديرها
صحيح؟ ثم علاقة الإنسان
مع الأهل والأقارب ومن ثم
العلاقة الأخيرة هي علاقة مع المجتمع.
لذلك .
يجب أن ننتبه .
هذا الشق الأول من ماذا؟ من الحل الأشمل
والأقوى صحيح؟ الشق الثاني من الحل الأشمل
والأقوى ، وهو أن يتعاون كل
شرفاء الأمة أمثالكم .
وكل المخلصين للأمة أمثالكم .
لإشاعة مناخ من الوعي .
وتعزيز القيم النبيلة .
وضبط الاستخدام .
موفقين الحضور الكريم نريد بناء جيل
يتمتع بشخصية أخلاقية وإبداعية.
مع المحافظة على الأصالة وتحقيق المعاصرة .
لأن .
أبناؤنا بحاجة لنا .
والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته .